let's get back to the phones where
people are waiting we will go first to
our caller from country code 96 country
code 96 who is this hello yes can you
hear me yes I can
I'm from Jordan hey how are you - good
I'm doing good my question is setting
aside the neutral need for visas and
Palestine do you think do you think we
should support the BDS movement if not
what oh so we did a deep dive on the
deal a couple of days ago when when it
first came out and the deal is basically
a joke I mean you have impeached Donald
Trump and indicted Benjamin Netanyahu
saying hey we made a deal and it's a
it's a complete farce it has no
possibility of really accomplishing
anything now that being said I don't
personally support the BDS movement but
I do want to see a Middle East peace
process move forward I've outlined in
detail exactly how I would see that
happening so I won't do it again since I
spent about 15 minutes earlier this week
doing it for my audience but know that
the deal the deal that was announced by
Trump and Netanyahu is basically a joke
and we think we should take it do you
think you should that that who's that do
you think Palestinians should take the
deal yeah interesting why is that well
the first time a border sorry what was
that I miss that well we think the
border finally yes it would establish or
it would establish it's a path to a
Palestinian state with a lot of caveats
and question marks and requirements but
there is a path that we already lost the
war so we get what you get so you you
live in Jordan but are you Palestinian I
gather yeah I see and you you would like
this deal you want the deal to be taken
well
I don't like it but I would like be
finally I see and I don't think we gotta
win another way interesting okay so did
you like to see I read I read that
Palestinian leaders rejected the deal
outright because it includes some
annexation of West Bank land how do you
feel about that well if you live in
Palestine already annexed are you
talking about in other words you don't
see any practical difference innocence
I'm trying to trying to follow yeah if
you go to Palestine there is a military
checkpoint yes there's the army can can
can go ahead and whatever whenever they
like interesting so you you you would
take the deal do you are the people
friends and family of yours are they on
board or do they have a different view
my family would like museum I see I say
yeah that that's not right okay listen I
think I understood your name was was
Amaru is that was that right did I have
that right
okay all right very good listen I so
appreciate hearing from you and I wish
you best of luck we'll put you in our
caller ID system and I hope to hear from
you again all right all right take care
very interesting phone call